this week on world stories the boomin
avocado farming in Uganda and special
tours glorifying China's communist
leaders but we begin in Germany Ziya
corn is a berlin-based painter and
photographer
despite her blindness she's mastered the
art of visual expression in a world of
darkness Xillia corn is blind she can't
see colors outlines or even light but
she can recognize them by using her
other senses and that is how she chooses
her subjects when I'm alone I take
pictures according to the sounds the
smell or the mood of the city for
example now I can feel the pavement
that's a little different
so I'll take pictures of that or that
bird just now I want to capture it in my
photographs as a child Xillia corn could
still see and she used to photograph and
paint a lot but that changed when at the
age of 12 she lost her eyesight in a car
accident it wasn't until she was in her
40s that a professional photographer
encouraged her to start again by
exploring the world in her own way
that's when I realized wow this opens up
a dialog between the sighted and the
blind it was so interesting that I
decided to continue I've been taking
pictures ever since her husband often
helps by telling her what the things she
touches and he is look like
sylia Khan's pictures capture everyday
objects in a new light she can also
discern color using a special sensing
device for blind people ah
you see it squeaks like that so it's
lighter working with light is a special
challenge and we used different types of
lamps I was the model and tried to feel
the light on my skin you can play a lot
with a light and shadow and I wanted to
find out how to do that in a controlled
way but it's quite difficult as a blind
person sylia con can't see the pictures
she has taken for that she needs the
help of a sighted person gray here and
white here and then it narrows all the
way down to here it depends on how the
person describes it my husband has known
me for so long that he knows exactly
what to say so that I can picture it
myself then it's almost like seeing it
with my own eyes but there is no
question about who decides whether a
picture should be exhibited well it's me
ultimately she does they're her pictures
sometimes he tries to nudge me in a
certain direction but it mostly doesn't
work the result is a window into Zelia
Kahn's view of the world
Hoss is an increasingly popular variety
of avocado especially in Europe farmers
in Uganda are now diversifying their
crops in order to profit from the boom
in demand for this superfood
once upon a time coffee was grown here
but these days the NASA is used to
prepare avocado seeds Ugandan farmers
are responding to soaring demand for the
fruit farmers want magetta two things
that entice them into any production
that is the market for their product and
a good price so we found a good market
for this product that has been the
export market this farm in central ganda
produces different varieties some types
such as has a popular on the
international market the level product
productivity varies depending on the age
of the tree and on the size of the farm
and the nature of the source to give you
an example of a farm a tree which is
between two and half years three years
we passes on African give us like 30 50
kgs to 450 depending on the variety but
the livery often proves a challenge
when it rains roads in some parts of the
country become impossible
in agendas capital Kampala exporters say
they can't meet demand KK foods one of
Uganda's largest exporters ships at
least 30 tonnes to Europe every month
Mikado would be okay if we had
commercial farmers of avocado tree and
also if we had the cold chain to to
maintain its quality beef right Arabs in
the market it would be much better
because we pick from farmers who have
trees in their backyard there is no
official data to show how much Uganda's
avocado trade is worth but exporters
point to an upward trend South Africa
already ranks among the top avocado
exporting countries in the world and
farmers elsewhere in Africa are hoping
to tap into the growing market to
the personality cults surrounding Mao
Zedong continues to impact on Chinese
society towards retracing the footsteps
of the former leader attract thousands
of pilgrims while also serving the
current government's propaganda strategy
it's known as red tourism Chinese
farmers living a carefree life in the
countryside suddenly Chiang kai-shek's
Nationalist troops destroy their idiom
these are scenes from the Chinese Civil
War of the 1940s we enacted four old and
young
every day visitors can see how Mao
Zedong's outnumbered communist troops
beat back the nationalist advance
performance is part of the tourist
program in the northern city of Yin on
the way that Chairman Mao liberated and
conquered Yin an act then it was really
spectacular Wendy and his sister are
spending their school holidays here with
their grandparents they want to do their
part for the children's education the
children should learn more about the
history of the revolution how Mao
conquered the whole country from here
and founded the new China the Communists
entrenched themselves in yen on to
escape their enemy after the revolution
the city became a place of pilgrimage
now more tourists come here than ever
before there is a clear propaganda
purpose behind the tools like Mao
President Xi wants to be idolized the
personality cult of China's most
powerful man is rife in the village of
young jaha an hour's drive away one of
millions of Chinese youth who Mao exiled
to the countryside she had to learn from
the farmers in this village chairman she
lived in this cave with a comrade the
photos are of his time in the village
have a look villagers build cave homes
that protected them from the harsh
mountain climate the official tour
guides say she learned to understand the
common people here
I claimed I was a tourist journalists
aren't welcome here in yen on the quang
family has reached the cave where Mao
once lived
but there's zero criticism of the late
chairman here and no mention of the
millions of people who died because of
his policy everyone has flaws no one is
perfect but Mao led China out of misery
and that's what counts
the revolution tour is almost over only
one more stop today and then the
children will have completed this part
of their read education
and we close with South Africa for
residents of Cape Town
baboons are a major pest locals are now
using a noisy but humane deterrent
toward the animals off a baboon burglary
in South Africa's Cape Peninsula people
versus primate is an almost daily
occurrence
thanks to brazen baboons in search of
their next meal Pat Riley has seen her
fair share of the monkey business
there are lot of them in Cape Town and
they're coming to your house and they
make an awful mess and you just got to
live with it but not too bad they've
been in my house quite often but they're
not aggressive I didn't find them
aggressive and they're not really
interested in you they were they were
looking for food that's what they are
looking for to drive the monkeys out of
urban areas conservationists from the
human wildlife solutions organization
have been testing a new strategy GPS
collars are used to track the baboon's
movements once the pesky primates get
close to town outcome the boom boxes you
play calls pretending that the are
predators there alarm call signs are
printed signs of animals being killed
they're scared to go over there you add
a few bangs from a bear banger that
reinforces the scariness and they avoid
the area with the help of predators such
as lions leopards and hyenas the aim is
to create what they call a landscape of
fear an imaginary boundary that the
monkeys do not dare to cross for
villagers in nearby hermanus it's music
to their ears
we've noticed in the last two weeks
since the this team arrived with a what
they call the virtual fence and we've
heard like literally now the dunes for
the last two weeks so we will be saying
is it our imagination or there's
suddenly Nova goons but they are
suddenly Nova
at stake is the region's famed baboon
population until recently the cheeky
monkeys would have been shot following
positive results the plan is now to rule
out the system in other Cape Town
suburbs hopefully ensuring that fewer
and fewer light-fingered friends are
killed unnecessarily
you